- [Tyler] Three, two, one.
(cameras clicking)
- This is one of the
first steps in a trend
that could upend the way movies are made.
Her purse was full of useless trash!
AI gives Hollywood producers
the ability to capture a scan of a star
and use it to do, well,
pretty much anything.
For example, neither of
these guys is the real me.
But the technology used to
do that comes with big risks,
especially for actors.
So I visited the CAA Vault.
- [Jack] We'll just step you in.
- [Erich] A studio created
by one of Hollywood's top talent agencies
to give actors control
of their digital doubles.
- There's no way to imagine
a future world without this.
- I don't quite know
what to anticipate here
but I'm excited to see what happens.
(air whooshes)
The CAA Vault houses
four different stations
that record an actor's body,
face, movements, and voice.
I feel like Jodie Foster in "Contact."
- Yeah.
- They should've sent a poet.
Dominic Ridley,
the director of VFX company
Clear Angle Studios,
works with CAA to create
these digital scans.
- With shooting those 17
different lighting fires,
we get to see how the light
is reacting to your materials
and your skin, et cetera.
- The first step in the
process is a 3D full body scan.
Why is this the pose?
- So this is basically just allowing us
to capture all the inside
of your arm and hands
while still being nice and relaxed.
- It's hard not to be a little nervous.
(cameras clicking)
- [Tyler] And that's it.
1 1/2 seconds, that just
is your full body capture.
- It's like a red carpet.
It shoots 17 different
lighting environments
in just 1.2 seconds.
(cameras clicking)
Those few seconds capture
more than 200 images
that look like these.
Later, all of the images will be used
in a process called photogrammetry,
which brings together
hundreds of 2D images
in order to create a 3D image of my body.
(air whooshes)
The next step in the process
is a range of motion scan.
- Once you start feeling
that kind of tension,
don't go too far past that.
- Okay.
It's just like following a workout video.
- Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
- This is for all the beach scenes
you're filming me in.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- [Erich] As the technology
has grown more popular in the industry,
actors are worried about
their digital doubles
being used without their consent.
The use of AI doubles was
a major sticking point
in the recent union negotiations
between actors and studios.
- [All] AI, bye-bye!
- I'd imagine AI is a bigger
and bigger part of your day.
- Yeah, AI became something
that we as a company were
aware of a long time ago.
- [Erich] Bryan Lourd is CEO
of the Creative Artists Agency
which represents actors like
Tom Hanks, Cate Blanchett,
and Zendaya,
and is the company beyond the CAA Vault.
- What we believe is that an individual,
whether you're famous or not,
should own your digital presence
and the simple concept of the Vault
was to get out ahead of this.
- [Erich] As the tech
becomes more accessible,
AI doubles could change
the way actors work.
For example, they could
avoid hours in their trailer
thanks to digital makeup
or they could use their
double for reshoots
while they move on to another project.
So far, there's been little protection
around how these digital doubles are used.
There isn't any federal law
protecting this kind of likeness
and local laws vary from state to state.
Many scans are owned
by studios, not actors.
And payment is also an issue.
How much should an actor make
when their double is used
instead of them?
Outside of work, anyone
can create their own scans
to make deepfakes that do or say anything.
- I'm gonna show you some magic.
- [Erich] The agency says the CAA Vault
is aimed at solving these issues
since all of the scans taken at the Vault
belong to the actors.
So that means, at the end of the day,
my digital identity and all
of the scans used to create it
will belong to me.
That includes my next one,
a face scan in a machine called Dorothy.
- She encapsulates the highest technology
that we have at Clear Angle Studios
and in this system we're
gonna capture your face
in the highest detail,
both for a 3D scan, we can
do 4D scanning as well.
- Do you feel like you're
living in the future?
- No, my wife keeps me very grounded.
- Ah.
- Yep.
- [Erich] It captures
the face in two sessions.
The first for use with photogrammetry,
like in the full body scan.
- [Jack] What this does
is it just allows very,
very high qualitative alignment
and when you're a 3D model,
we can stabilize your 3D models
around the cubes on your head.
- [Erich] Each three second capture
grabs nearly 700 images.
This is followed by a series
of 76 different facial expressions
with just a single flash.
- [Jack] That was the
perfect outer brow raise
with this one, yeah.
- Oh, really?
The second stage is a
capture for generative AI,
which is a series of images
used by a machine learning platform
to recreate my image in 2D.
This includes the full
spectrum of mouth movements,
so my double can say any
word and appear authentic.
To give the system enough options,
I had to express a lot of
emotions about a beige fox.
The quick beige fox jumped in
the air over each thin dog.
The lights flash in very
specific patterns in this scan
to simulate different environments.
- And then we can replicate
the lighting from the set
in here and then redo the performance.
- Those scans come out
looking something like this,
allowing my double to be placed
in different environments
without the lighting looking unnatural.
These days, a chicken leg is a rare dish.
Then, the last stage, a scan of my voice.
I could try to do, like, a British accent.
The hogs were fed
chopped corn and garbage.
So why do you have me
saying these sentences?
Why do we care so much
about women with trash in
their purses and smoky flames?
- These are words and phrases
that will cover every possible sound
to make other phrases or words
happen, if that makes sense.
- [Erich] So from this collection
of random sounds and sentences,
you can have me say or do anything?
- Yes. (laughs)
- CAA then stores the scans
and says they have a layer of
security to protect the data.
Then I could hand off my
digital mask to VFX studios,
like CAA Vault's partner Deep Voodoo.
They can then make a digital
rendering of, well, me.
While the tech is a major talking point
in Hollywood right now,
CAA says it's not just
actors being scanned.
Musicians, athletes,
directors, and content creators
have also gone through the process.
But there's a lot of uncertainty
about this technology.
For example, it's unclear
how it could impact work in Hollywood
for people who aren't major stars,
or what its implications
might be in politics,
or our everyday lives.
I feel like that when
you see this technology,
the first response is, "Oh
my god, this is so cool."
And the second response is,
"This could ruin the world."
- "Oh my god."
Yeah, yeah.
- Does it keep you up at night
and do you worry about that
as you try to in some ways
advance this technology?
- Yes.
I mean, I think it was a
big fundamental question
that we had to ask ourselves is,
"Do we bury our heads in the sand
or do we embrace this and go after it?"
And so we think we all have a
responsibility to embrace it,
but to embrace it with some
sort of ethics and morals
and fairness in mind.
(soft music)